nos preguntan cuántos palillos serán
necesarios para formar la 50a figura en
esta sucesión y aquí ya nos dibujaron
los primeros cuatro términos este es el
primero el segundo el tercero y el
cuarto la sucesión
obviamente continúa lo que nosotros
queremos saber es cuántos palillos tiene
la figura que estaría en el lugar 50 así
que empecemos a analizando qué pasa en
esta primera figura en esta primera
figura tengo un palillo dos palillos
tres bolillos cuatro tornillos cinco
palillos y seis palillos así que hay
seis palillos bien y ahora en la segunda
que pasa pues para empezar tengo una
copia de la primera figura esta primera
casa la podría pensar como una copia de
la primera figura de modo que tengo los
seis palillos de la primera 12
4 1 2 3 4 5 6 claro y adicionalmente
tengo otros 5 palillos noten que ya no
tuve que construir por así decirlo una
pared izquierda porque ya podía usar la
derecha de la primera casa así que esto
no podría pensar como los 6 para niños
de la primera figura más los 5 palillos
de esta segunda casita y eso me da un
total de 11 palillos en esta figura para
la tercera de nuevo tengo una copia de
la figura número 2 y aquí tengo los 11
palillos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
y acá tengo otros 5 palillos adicionales
y nuevamente no tuve que construir la
pared izquierda de la última casita de
la 'roja' entonces tengo 11 palillos de
la figura número 2 + 5 palillos
adicionales
11 5 palillos y eso me da el gran total
de 16 palillos así que cada vez que
agregó una casita cada vez que avanzó en
la sucesión lo que está pasando es que
le estoy sumando cinco el número de
palillos anterior es decir el término 4
sería 16 más cinco que sería 21 y
ustedes pueden checar eso bien entonces
volvamos a la pregunta de cuántos
palillos se requiere si yo estoy en el
enésimo termino en el enésimo termino
enésimo término de la sucesión
o sea o en la enésima figura entonces
yo estoy en el n
uno más un término
ok porque n es igual a n
11 y porque esto es útil pues ahora
puedo decir que si por ejemplo estoy en
la figura 2 entonces estoy en la figura
1 más 1 o si estoy en la figura 3 estoy
en la figura 2 más 1 lo interesante aquí
es que yo podría escribir una fórmula
para el número de palillos número de
palillos en la enésima figura
y palillos
cuántos va a ser pues tengo los seis
palillos de la primera figura
y por cada término que haya avanzado
después de la primera figura tengo que
sumar 5 palillos así que voy a sumar 5
por n menos 1 gay porque no tengo que
volver a contar la primera figura esa ya
la tengo entonces esta es una fórmula
para el número de palillos o quizás
quizás también le sirva a pensarlo de
este modo podría imaginar que tengo una
figura digamos la figura 0 o el término
0 en mi sucesión y el término 0 solo
consiste en un palillo es la pared de
izquierda por así decirlo podría pensar
en esta pared como esta de modo que si
lo pienso así en la enésima figura el
número de palillos en la enésima figura
en palillos
la enésima figura
encima
figura
cuántos van a ser pues tengo un palillo
de la figura cero y ahora sí ya que
obtengo la pared izquierda no la tengo
que construir en el término 1 ni en el
término 2 ni en el término 3 porque ya
la tengo en el término 0 entonces ahora
sólo voy a agregar 5 palillos ahora sí
por cada etapa en la que esté ya no
necesito n menos uno sino ahora
simplemente necesito 5 por n
veamos si esto funciona digamos que
estoy en el paso 4 tengo uno más cuatro
por cinco que es uno más 20 que es 21
que es precisamente esto y coincide
también con esta fórmula 6 más 5 por 4
menos 14 menos 1 es 3 por 5 es 15 6 es
21 de hecho estas dos fórmulas son
equivalentes pero bueno contestemos la
preguntar cuántos palillos se requieren
para la 50 va a figurar
las 50 kva
figura
pues voy a tener uno más simplemente
sustituyó n igual a 50 así que uno más
50 por 5 y cuánto es esto 50 por 5 es
250 más uno sería 251 y no importa qué
fórmula usen de hecho vamos a ver que
esta fórmula se reduce a esta y el modo
de hacerlo pues simplemente va a ser
vamos a expandir esto voy a distribuir
al 5 y voy a escribir esto como 6 más 5
por n menos 5 ahora seis menos cinco es
simplemente uno y tengo este 5 n así que
esta fórmula y esta son la misma pero
esta era esta así que las dos fórmulas
coinciden no importa cómo lo hagan